when Kate Flannery exited the office for
the last time she did so having created
and embodied Meredith one of the
funniest secondary characters on
television but just what has Flannery
been up to since leaving Meredith Palmer
behind after nine long seasons the
office left the air on a high note with
the iconic wedding of two main
characters Dwight and Angela a send-off
that sat well with Flannery speaking to
the blog how to be a redhead she
explained I am so proud of the ending of
the office I felt that everything was
wrapped up so nicely it's added funny
and thoughtful and everything you want
in the finale I am so sad but I am so
proud it's a great feeling to be part of
such a respected and honored project the
end of the show also made Flannery feel
nostalgic and reflective which she
discussed in an essay she wrote for
Huffington Post
she wrote to be part of an ensemble on
TV as a gift I stopped counting lines I
was disappointed at first when my lines
would get cut but it dawned on me I
don't need to be the meat I don't need
to be the side dish I can be the onions
it's good to be the onions I fall in
love with make it when it came to
summing up the offices appeal to fans
and audiences around the world
Flannery put it just about as succinctly
as you can she wrote
Abraham Lincoln said most people are as
happy as they make up their minds to be
this show made its mind up to have heart
and soul and treat the audience like it
had a brain nowadays Flannery gets to
flex her musical muscles and her comedy
lounge act the lampshades in which she's
joined by fellow actor Scott Robinson
Flannery describes the act as a
male-female duo fresh from the cruise
ship circuit spinning pop and rock into
comedy gold as they work out the kinks
in their amusingly tortured relationship
the dual plays regularly mostly in
Southern California comedy clubs and for
a number of years they had a standing
gig at the IO Theatre in Hollywood
Flannery says it's been musically
interesting
we will gig out and host stand-up nights
and we've done a lot of charity events
and some private parties it's very
portable show so it's been really really
great for us
we've gotten around a lot doing it and
we've met a lot of people because of it
in addition to the lampshades flattery
also sings and performs with Glee star
Jane Lynch and Lynch's comedy cabaret
show see Jane sing the pair's working
relationship goes back to the early days
of a stage show called the real live
Brady Bunch
when Flannery served as Lynch's
understudy and acted in several of the
plays non Brady roles and while much of
see Jane sing seems to be improvised
Lynch says this simply isn't the case I
like to script every damn moment I build
a cage but then I bounce around freely
within the cage
Flannery herself however does seem to
keep things fresh it's always 360
nothing's the same twice for her so and
that keeps me alive and going what is
she gonna do now a film variety called a
thoroughly ingratiating touchingly
heartfelt comedy fourth man out tells
the story of Adam a small-town car
mechanic who after a night of drinking
comes out to his three lifelong friends
who are surprised to learn he is gay the
bulk of the film finds them attempting
to maintain the equilibrium in their
friendship while helping Adam find a
relationship of his own Flannery plays
Adams mother Karen and says the film is
a byproduct of an increasingly tolerant
audience and society in an interview
with the film's cast
she told Hollywood Chicago the world has
changed so much and younger kids have so
much less judgement about everything
they don't care to draw lines between
people I think that is fantastic and
this movie is the evolution of coming
out in America this is an amazing story
that represents that change
Parker Young who played one of Adams
friends in the film agreed he said our
generation is more aware of what we
think about it as individuals and we're
not listening to negative backlash when
we don't agree with it Flannery
maintains a robust presence on Twitter
and Instagram tweeting and posting
photos of a number of things including
her exploits offstage her time spent
with friends and other celebrities and
her slate of current and upcoming
projects she is also fond of retweeting
fans posts and a seemingly endless
stream of memes both of the office in
general and of her character Meredith
specifically
she doesn't always feel comfortable in
the virtual realm though in an interview
with Google
Flannery noted that engaging with fans
online can often be pretty difficult I
have to be a little more self conscious
than I normally would be and I just have
to sort of figure out like okay what
what am I really gonna who-who needs to
know what in fact she sees a problem
with social media personalities in
general I just feel like sometimes
there's such an egocentric thing that
happens with the sense of celebrity even
at the smallest level in the years since
the office closed for good Flannery has
filled her on-screen time with a range
of different projects most of them
independently produced films and
television shows she plays the role of
nosy next-door neighbor mrs. Jenkins and
stuck a 20-17 movie in which the main
character Darby is sentenced to a month
of house arrest in the same house as her
ex-boyfriend and his new fiancee
Flannery also took a part in fishbowl
California a film about a drunk
chronically ill Widow who takes in an
aimless 20-something finally Flannery
plays principal saperstein in the hulu
comedy series all night which deadline
describes as centering on an overnight
lock-in graduation party in which a
group of new grads will do whatever it
takes to make their remaining high
school dreams come true while none of
these projects have quite constituted an
office sized hit each has benefited
hugely from Flannery's wit and comedic
chops and considering the current pace
at which she's working it's safe to
assume that more shows and movies will
be added to the list in due course check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
you
[Music]